the video you're about to see was
originally posted on the blue color
coder youtube channel
so after you watch it if you like it be
sure to jump over to that channel which
is linked to in the description above
for more videos just like this one micro
front ends or the ability to
share visual components between
two applications and have them live
updating
it's a great concept and we've been
talking about it now for a little while
but the mechanics of it can be daunting
so we're gonna solve a lot of that
on this blue collar coder video
i'm jack harrington add to her on
twitter and i really appreciate you
coming by
and spending some time with me so
there's a couple of different problems
that we're going to solve
and we're going to solve them using
module federation which is a new
feature that's baked right into webpack
five it's totally free
to you it's really exciting stuff so the
first thing we're gonna solve
is the infrastructure problem the
ability to just get the code
between those two applications and get
it live updating
module federation makes it so easy that
in this video we're going to be able to
go on from there
and actually address some more
fundamental problems when it comes to
microphone ends
for example the ability to share state
between microfront ends that are
instantiated in different locations on
the page and individually
we're going to solve that in this video
and it's really exciting and i can't
wait to show it to you
but even better we're actually going to
show you
something you probably haven't seen
before on any video which is the ability
to have the host page
engage in that conversation around the
micro front-end state
so it's really cool it allows the
host page to actually integrate even
better with the micro front end
experience
it's really exciting we're going to do
it both between two react
applications as well as between a react
application
and a vanilla application it's exciting
stuff if you haven't seen module
federation before
you'd want to check this out if you have
seen module federation before you're
still going to want to check this out
because this is stuff
you probably haven't seen before let's
just jump right into the code
okay so here's the three different apps
that we are working on today
this is the components test app
we're going to call that growlers and
that's going to have
our different micro fe components in
kind of a test page
setting and then over here in react host
these are going to use those micro fee
components
in a different setup so over here
they're kind of just on the left in the
middle
and on the right over here the search is
on top on this
column there's only two columns and then
the cart is now below that
and then there's also this additional ui
that's custom
to this particular app but that still
uses the data source here so that's
actually pretty cool
and then finally there is the vanilla
host so this is just vanilla
html there's no react behind it it is
getting
web packed and that's how it's actually
importing this stuff but it's a
similar sort of thing so this is my
local kind of neighborhood tap house
and there's this is the tap list we saw
before
as well as the search but now it's up
here here's another
data driven thing that is running off of
this tap list
and is dynamic so they change this value
then you can see this change as well so
now vanilla
is also subscribed to this data source
so we're going to make all that happen
so let me just go back over to the code
real quick the finished code
and there's three different directories
here there's growlers which is that
first test app over here there is host
react
react host over there and host vanilla
which is this
vanilla host right here so we're just
going to start off with this
growler's one but i'm just going to look
at the finished code really quick
and just kind of give you a little bit
more detail here so we'll go into
constants and i'll change out this
mfe border just to show you where these
mfes are
so if you notice growlers has now added
this five pixel dashed border to each
one of these components
indicating that these are the different
micro fees and just to go through the
functionality here you can type search
you can go and say let's see upwards or
whatever
and you get it'll pair that down for you
you can also go and change this rating
in this alcohol rating over here and get
the different
variations you know it's just and it's
also pretty
so we also got that tap list that shows
that and then you can
click on any one of these you like and
add it to the cart which again
kind of takes the same data represents
it slightly differently
and then click checkout and clear the
card
so that's the basic functionality now
let's go over here and take a look at
react host and if i just hit refresh
right away we get the new code which is
really
cool it's absolute live updating so this
host right here is looking at this site
to go and get the code
for these components this is not an npm
it's not going through any of that it is
literally just going grabbing that code
and that's why the
next time i hit refresh it's working
just fine so
again we have the tab list over here
we've got the search box and they have
the checkout
and then we've got our custom code right
in here which goes and takes
the data from this the back end store
the client slide back in store that's
actually running all this
and then visualize that a little bit
differently again so that's actually
really really cool
and finally vanilla host i'll refresh
one more time and yeah
now we can again see those micro fees in
their context
away we go so the way that we're going
to get started with this
is by closing out all these tabs
and then going over here to the starter
for mike refi
simplified which is in github
and before we get started the one thing
i really want you to pay attention to as
we go along here is the amount of time
that we're spending on the
infrastructure of just getting the code
from one page to another just
kind of think about that and think about
how micro fees have been done the past
and how hard it's been to get that code
around okay so let's do an npx d-git on
this
and then we'll bring up vs code so this
is the starting point
for the code that we saw before we got
that growlers directory
and then within that we've got our
constants that one mfp border that i
showed you before
as well as the different components that
we've got so
we're just going to go and bring this up
and then i'll start it
okay looks pretty good but we don't have
any
data or any connection between these
components these are all just
display components at this point so what
i want to do is actually
go and bring in a micro state manager
called valcio
and use that as the back plane to move
to first get the data and then go and
move it between these different
components and you might ask yourself
well why are you using
valshio well valshio actually has a very
interesting
attribute to it and that's that it does
not require a provider
so there's no requirement on the
consuming application to kind of wrap
all this
in any kind of provider which is really
handy
so the first thing i'm going to do is
add valcio
and now i'm going to start making my
store
and to get started on a store the first
thing i need to do is import a proxy
function
from valcio
and then i'm going to define because i'm
in typescript what i want the store to
look like
so the first thing i need to export an
interface for that
and there's a couple of things i can do
right away for example i can do the
search text
which is going to be a string the
alcohol limit which would be a number
and then i need the type definition for
a beverage and thankfully i've already
got that
so this is the beverage data that we're
getting and
we actually have json files for that so
these are the
for example the perhaps at my local
happy valley growlers
so we got this beverage definition and
i'll just
use that
and so now i need a list of all the taps
as well as all the ones that pass the
search text and alcohol limit filter
and then all the ones that are in the
cart
and that's our store how cool is that
all right so what we need to do is
actually go and build that store
so we create a proxy and then we give it
the type of the store
and then we give it our initial state
and then we just export that okay so the
next thing we need to do is actually
load some data into this store before we
go and look at it so let's
go and create a new exposed function
called load
where i give it the name in this case
like hp tap list
and it goes and fetches that data and
then puts it into that valio store
so it'll take the name of the client in
this case like for example hv tab list
and then i'll run that fetch
and we're currently on localhost 8080 so
i'll do that
and then give it the name of the client
and json and then once we get that we'll
turn that into json
and once you've got that json data we
will set the taps
and the way that we do that is the
hardest way you can possibly imagine
you just set the value
that's it that's all you need to do but
in this case we also want to set that
filter taps just to get it started
but really we actually want to do the
filter so let's actually go and just
implement that
real quick
first we'll create a regular expression
for the search
make it case insensitive and then we'll
just filter out the taps
and we're gonna be searching on the
beverage name and the amount of alcohol
first we'll get the right beverage name
and make sure the alcohol is below what
we want
and then the last thing to do would be
to just take off the top say 15 or so
okay looking pretty good let's go and
run that
so now i've actually got to display it
somewhere so the first thing i want to
try to do
is do the taps list so let's go over
here to components and taps
and the way that you use a valshio store
is you
well you created a proxy so now you want
to use that proxy
so you import that from valcio
and now we got to bring in the store so
let's go do that
and then we got to use it
and that's all it takes to get the
current value of filtered taps
so let's go and take that and put that
in for that array over there
save that out and see we're doing
okay so what we need to do is call that
load function
on the store so let's go do that
and now we've got to load that list from
the hv tab list
all right looking pretty good but you're
not connected to
this search or this alcohol yet or to
the cart so
some things to do here but overall
looking pretty good so far
so in order to go and connect that up to
the
search text we need first some setters
so let's go and
back over to the store and go and add
those setters
so let me go and create some setters for
set search text and set alcohol limit
and while we're here you might as well
just do add to cart
and to do all that all we need to do is
just push this into the cart
so again the reason that we're using
valshio is it doesn't require a provider
so let's go again let's have a look over
here at the
app and we can see that we're bringing
in this search the tabs in the cart
and then we just go and put them inside
the grid so we've got up here
the shocker provider that's giving us
our css
classes for chakra ui which is awesome
then we got a grid within that and then
we just got the basically the three
components
so there's no provider nothing like that
no no redux provider or anything like
that
all right so the next thing we need to
do is go over to our search
and wire those up so it's all working
let me use taps as a starting point for
that so we'll bring in use proxy again
as well as the store
and we also need the setters
and let's go bring in that use proxy
so in this case we want the search text
as well as the alcohol limit
so let's try out this input field first
set the value
and then create the on change handler
and we'll just call that set search text
okay let's actually give that a try
before we continue on
muffin there we go that
is so fast and so cool
all right let's get rid of that and
let's do the alcohol limit that's down
on this slider over here
so we'll set the default value to the
alcohol limit
as well as the value
and then we also need an onchange
and it just gives us back the value so
we'll just go set that
okay let's give that a try
that's cool wow
how fast is that all right and the last
thing we want to do is go and implement
this add to cart functionality as well
as the card over here so let's work on
let's work on that card first
so take this over into cart take the
store
over into cart
and take the use proxy
that into cart and all we need from that
is
the cart that's an array so we'll just
drop it in here
cool this is basically all set up for
you so that this is actually pretty easy
i don't want to spend a whole lot of
time on this but i want you to
understand
how valshio works because that's not
really the magic here
the magic happens in a few minutes when
we try out the module federation stuff
so
that's going to be exciting all right
let's go back over to our beverage cart
at this point and we'll go and implement
the button
which is add to cart down here so in
this case the only thing we need to
bring in is that add to cart
because well we don't actually need
anything from the store we're just gonna
add to it
and now we just use that down on that
button
okay let's give this a try oh
how cool is that okay so now we are
ready to roll
now we've got three different components
all of which are talking to valgio
and getting all that data and it's all
working great
so the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to use this webpack 5
starter for react in typescript
and the reason for that is well one
we're going to create the react host so
we want to have react all baked into it
and two because we want to be on webpack
5 because webpack 5 supports this module
federation thing that we want to use to
share these components
and this is actually that infrastructure
bit that i talked about before
this is where we're going to start using
that so here we go so the first thing
we're going to do is
first de-get this i'm going to create a
new terminal over here
go back up a directory and now i'm going
to do that mpxd get
give it main on this one we're going to
call this
host react
all right let's go in and yarn that
and then to this i need to go and add
chakra ui because that's there's a
shared toolkit there
so let me go over to shopper ui
and bring in their get started and just
use that yarn ad here
okay so we got to go make a few changes
to this before we start up because it's
actually on 8080 already so we need to
go and
fix that let's go back over here to host
react
and webpack config and we'll change that
to 8081
just to get it out of the way and then
down here we will go and change this to
say
react host so this is the module
federation plugin and it's what's going
to allow us
to move the code from growlers over into
host react
so every one of these module federation
plugins needs to have a different name
and in this case i'm going to use this
as reactos we haven't actually haven't
made any changes over to growler yet
we'll do that in a second so let's fire
this up
all right looking pretty good i'm down
with this so the next thing we need to
do is go and export the components that
we've
created from growlers
so the way we do that is we go into this
webpack config
and then down here in the module
federation plugin we're going to call
this
growlers so down here on exposes we're
going to list
the different components that we want to
be exposed from this application so
let's give that a try
so first we'll expose say cart
and just give it the name so in this
case dot slash cart and then
source and components and then cart
and we'll do that for the three primary
ones
cart search and taps
now you do need to reboot here so let's
do that
all right seems to be happy with that
and then the last thing i need to do is
because we've got
that load function on store which is the
only way that you can go and tell it
what the
client is and what data to load the next
thing we need to do is export that
store so that we can then make that load
call so let's bring that over into
webpack config
and then just do store
and store
and now we're good to go all we need to
do is restart it now let's go over into
our consuming app
and go and set that up so here's our
webpack config
for the react host and what we need to
do is
specify that now growlers is a remote
we've got these components and they're
remote from us so we need to go and
specify we have a growlers remote
and then even a string and the first
part of the string is
the federated name so let's go back over
here to our webpack and fix
that and that is growlers
and then you give it at and then you
give it a url so the first part of the
url will be in this case when you're in
debug mode would be the localhost
like that but when you deploy to
production it would be
the production url so you'll need to go
and have a switch here between
the production mode and the development
mode to go and set that but that's
that's all pretty much standard webpack
so let's go and copy this
and the other thing you need is the
remote entry
so down here under name under file name
there's remote entry paste that in there
and click on that and that shows us our
remote entry
for growlers which has all of it in
there cart as well as everything else so
it's got store and all that so it looks
like we're good to go
so now that's all set up that is the
entire infrastructure
is going over here to the webpack config
of the
the thing that wants to expose
components or code
and then setting it as a remote for the
thing that wants to consume it the host
of it so we'll go and then
stop this and restart it
all right looking pretty happy so the
next thing we want to do is actually try
to use it so let's go back over here to
app.ts so the first thing we need to do
is import
that load
and then use growlers because that's the
name we specified and then the store
so in this case we're going to again
load that heavy value tap list so let's
go and just grab that
paste that in there let's see how that
works
seems to be doing okay so now let's
actually try and use a visual component
that's going to then use that store so
we'll use for example the taps
and then we just bring it in here
and away we go interesting though
it doesn't have all the styling on it so
i'm gonna go and
set up chakra because we want the
styling to work
isn't that nice drop that in there and
we'll just wrap this in a shocker
provider
oh that's much nicer now okay so now we
got the css
working so that's cool so now let's go
and actually replicate that two-column
layout system we had
so i'm gonna go down here create a new
div
and on that div i'll give it basically
the body
with a max width of 960 pixels
a margin of auto
a display of grid where we've got two
columns
and a little gap between them
okay looks good all right so now this is
in the
first column not quite where we want it
so let's go and create a div that'll
then hold the search and the cart
let's bring in the search in the cart
all right and now i can change that and
it works perfectly so add to cart
check out everything's really cool
actually you know we didn't specify this
checkout functionality so let's go do
that real quick
and noticing again it doesn't work here
right now and it doesn't work
here right now so this will be a good
demonstration of live updating so let's
go back over here
to the cart and we want to do is put a
click handler on
this checkout so i'm just going to use
store here and say
on click and just say the store.cart
is a nothing just like that
all right so let's go and add a few
things to the card over here
hit that button and it's gone nice again
so let's
click out over here nothing okay but if
i refresh and get new code
if i add to cart click checkout boom i
get the new functionality
so another test of that would be for
example doing that constant thing that i
showed you very early on
go and change out that mfv border
hit refresh and wow cool okay so this is
really
pretty neat so the next thing i want to
try out is
to do this in vanilla land so let's
actually try
this without react and the way that
we're going to do that is we're actually
going to go
and wrap the growler components so i'm
going to create a new directory
alongside components called vanilla
and then in that i'm actually going to
go and take a copy of app
and clone that and create a new one
called
say vanilla cart
paste that in there and i'm going to
pair this down a little bit so the first
thing i'm going to do is get rid of
these other imports i'm going to keep
shocker provider but get rid of this and
that
i'm going to get rid of the load as well
as the index.css
as well as this
and all i'm going to do is put the card
in there just the cart within the
shocker provider
so all i want is the right css
and the cart so this is pretty good but
what i really want is a
callable function and that function
should take a selector
and then run the react dom.render
and then instead of
document.getelementbyid we're going to
use a query selector
and just give it that selector there you
go
we'd be nice and call this a string
okay looking pretty good so now we need
versions of this for all three of those
components so
copy and paste that out and i'll create
a new one called
vanilla search
and all it does is just search
and then one more called vanilla taps
okay and now we're back into
infrastructure land we've got to go and
expose these again because they're not
currently exposed
i'm going to do that for all three of
them
okay and now the next thing to do is
restart
so everything looks good but we don't
have anybody using that yet so let's go
and create our vanilla app
so i'm going to use that same mpxd get
but we're essentially just
going to remove the react
so i'll yarn it
and i'll get rid of a few of these files
get rid of growlers
i'm going to actually go over here to
the webpack config and i'm going to
steal this remote
because it's going to be the same
between the two of them i'm going to put
that down in this webpack config
i'm going to change the port number to
82
scroll down here paste this into the
remote
and we'll call this one vanilla host
so now i'll remove react from the
vanilla one
and we'll go over here to our source and
our app
and we're not going to use any of this
really we're just going to import that
but we are going to import our
components
from growlers so let's actually go and
steal that code
over here i need to change it a little
bit but let's just go and grab that
and then in this case it's going to be
vanilla
and these are all functions that when
given a selector we'll put in that ui
so the next thing we need to do is
actually go and specify
our ui for this and the way that we do
that is through
the index html so what used to be the
way to do it was to have that app in
there
so let's go and make some changes to
this
and i'm going to do another two-column
layout so let's build that
and for the moment i'm just going to
drop in a spot for a logo
and then i'm going to drop in another
div that's going to have a spot for the
search
and then down below that i'm going to
have another grid
slightly differently spaced
that's going to have the tabs list and
then the cart
all right let's go start this up
okay and there's nothing there right now
now we need to use those vanilla
functions to go and point it at
these classes so for this case search
and we just give it dot and then search
let's try that out see if it works okay
so it's not showing up
so let's go check that out and see
what's going on okay ah all right so we
can't find the module component search
all right that's just a problem over on
the growler side so let's go and tweak
that
oh that'll work
and there you go wow that's really cool
but again you're not showing any taps or
anything like that so let's give that a
try
that is super cool look at this this is
on vanilla js
this has no react in it this is actually
going and getting react
enough to drive those components from
the other application
automatically for you because it's
required
to run these components but otherwise
this is absolutely just
vanilla js that just happens to be
bringing in
some functions and those functions just
happen to be running
micro fees that run react and having
that connection to it
okay so another thing we want to try out
was a lot
of micro fe frameworks concentrate on
just
the visual components but they really
don't give you a way
to make your own components that also
fit into that ecosystem
so i kind of want to show that in both
the react and vanilla versions so let's
go and
start off with creating a data component
in with react
so i'm going to base it on this i'm
going to grab this out of here
we'll call this data component
i'm going to use the proxy i'm going to
use the store
i'm also going to use the definition of
tap store
and we're going to call this data
component
and now what it's going to do is instead
of taking
visual components of the child it's
actually going to take a function
and we're going to give that function
the tap store
state so i'm going to specify that as
the
props for this component
but that child function is going to
return some react elements
and then to make that work well first
we've got the store already so let's
just
call that state and then we're just
going to call that function
and now let's export that
and also define that react element
okay looking pretty good now the next
thing we need to do is expose this
and restart the server and the only time
you need to restart the server is when
you're making changes to that webpack
config
and then we're going to go over and
consume it on the host react side
so first we need to import it
and then we're going to use it so down
here i'm going to use a data component
and then down inside of it i'm going to
go get the filter taps
and for the moment i'm just going to go
and json stringify that
oh okay looking gross
but fine now i'm not gonna do as much as
i did
in the example that you can get off of
github
i'm just going to go and say for example
grab out all the beverage names
and we'll just display all that
oh there you go and i can change this
and so we have now a component
that you can define on the consumer side
the behavior that you want to go and
connect to
that store dynamically and work with all
the micro fe components that are out of
the box
but you can go and create your own
component that visualize that data
in whatever way you want and the
complete interaction between those is
absolutely
seamless so think about how much
we've worked on the infrastructure of
this and just exposing
these components and all the mechanics
around that versus how much we've
actually done
in terms of the functionality of the
thing so we've created this
data component for example this is
really cool in that it allows the
consumer of this to go and
create a ui that's customized to them
which is
really interesting and it's very much on
the
what are we going to do with its side as
opposed to the mechanics of the actual
sharing of the code between these
applications
so let's see if we can do a similar sort
of thing on the vanilla javascript side
so the
way we're going to do that is we're
going to use a subscriber we're going to
export an ability to subscribe
from the store so we'll go over to the
store
and valio already has a subscriber
mechanism baked into it so we're going
to bring that in
and you also need a way to get a a
snapshot of the current data so
we'll bring that in as well
and so down here we're going to go and
create a new exported function called
subscribe
and it's going to take a callback
that gets called whenever our state
changes and it's going to call
with the state and return nothing
and then we're going to give back a an
unsubscribe essentially
so the first thing we're going to do is
call you back immediately with the
current state
so we're going to call callback
and then give it the snapshot of the
store
and then we're going to set us up with
valio so we're going to return
the valio subscribe
we're going to give it the store
and then we're going to give it a
function which is then going to call
that callback
save that out and now we're going to go
over to our vanilla
and put a spot in there where we can go
and take that
current list of beverages or whatever
and put them on the screen somewhere so
let's go and create that in the index
call this beverages
and now we'll go in here and we're going
to import subscribe
from the store as well
and then call it
give it a function it's going to take
the state
and for the moment this is console logit
and see if it's getting called
here's our vanilla version let's bring
up the console
looks like it's getting called already
if i change this again
oh that is so neat okay cool so all i
need to do now
is go and just set that text in there to
whatever we want
so i'm just going to peel off again
filter taps
and then grab this element
and then set us in our html to the
filter taps
where you grab the beverage name off
each one
and then let's make it comma separated
all right let's give it a go oh wow and
it worked
right away how cool is that so not only
do you get that
additional mutable functionality
in a react context that makes that
micrography experience so much cooler
and so much more integrated but you can
also do it in a vanilla js context as
well
this is so cool all of that code is
available to you on github
and i really encourage you to try it out
for yourself module federation is
phenomenal stuff it makes doing this
really really easy
check it out and enjoy okay i hope you
enjoyed that i hope you learned a lot
more about module federation
and if you want there's a book on it
it's written by myself
and zach jackson there's a link to that
in the description of course
also in the description is a link to our
discord server where you can jump on and
have a chat with us
as well as the newsletter that'll get
you access to these videos a day earlier
than everyone else but if you have any
questions or comments just be sure to
put those in the comments section down
below if you just want to say oh wow
that's so cool
i can't believe that's amazing yeah just
just hit it in the comments or say hey i
don't get this at all help me out
put that in the comments too i'm totally
down for that of course in the meantime
from me to you be happy be healthy
and be safe